- But the New Frontier of which I speak
is not a set of promises,
it is a set of challenges.
- As his family, we're
proud what he stood for
and his continuing power.
- He had the courage to plainly admit
America's own shortcomings,
to then lay out bold plans
to address those problems and
to ask his fellow Americans
for help in solving them.
And in doing so, he inspired a generation
to enter public service.
- Kennedy symbolized a set
of values and attitudes
about civic life that made
it such an attractive calling.
The idea that politics
could in fact be a noble
and worthwhile pursuit, the
notion that our problems,
while significant were
never insurmountable.
- It sums up not what I intent
to offer the America people
but what I intend to ask of them.